let me ask the big uh you're you're
friends with manolas he's obsessed with
this question so let me ask the big
ridiculous question about
the meaning of life uh do you have uh
you ever think about this one you ever
uh ponder the the reason we're here
he's descends the vapes on this spinning
ball
in the middle of nowhere yeah i don't i
don't think
one ends up in the field of space
propulsion without thinking of
these existential questions uh yeah all
the time
or bill is a business yeah i know right
um yeah we've touched on a lot of the
different
pieces of this i think so
i i have a bunch of thoughts um
i do think that you know the goal isn't
the meaning isn't anymore
just to be like a petri dish of bacteria
that reproduces and
um you know where survival and
reproduction are the main
objectives and maybe it's because now
we're
able to answer these ask those questions
um that's maybe the turning point
um and instead i i think it's really the
pursuit and generation of knowledge
and and so if if we're taken out by an
asteroid or something
i think that it will have been a
you know meaningful endeavor if somehow
our knowledge about the universe is
preserved somehow
um and the next civilization isn't
starting
over again um so that that's
that's i always yeah i
resonated with that that i always loved
the mission of google
from the early days of making the
world's
sort of information and knowledge
searchable i always loved that idea i
was
loved i was donated as people should to
wikipedia
uh i just love wikipedia i feel like
it's
the it that's one of the greatest
accomplishments of just
a humanity of us together especially
wikipedia and this opens
like in this open community way putting
together different knowledge just
like on everything we've talked about
today i'm sure there's a wikipedia page
about ion engines and i'm sure it's
pretty good
yeah like it's i don't know that's
that's incredible
and obviously that can be preserved
pretty efficiently at least wikipedia
and you just you'll be like the human
civilization is all like burning up in
flames
as there's this one usb drive slowly
traveling yeah
wikipedia on it that's on
from the beginning of our chat that one
lonely spacecraft
it just means wikipedia and then
it will have been a civilization well
spent um so pushing that knowledge along
yeah through like one little discovery
at a time is is one of is a core aspect
to the meaning of it
of it all yes and i also i can i haven't
yet
figured out what the connection
you know an explanation i'm happy with
yet for how it's connected but
um evolving beyond
just the the survival piece too i think
like we touched on
the the emotional aspect something in
there about
cooperation and you know love and
so i in my day-to-day that just boils
down to
you know the pursuit of knowledge or
improving the human condition and being
kind love and knowledge yeah
exactly so i'm pretty at peace with that
as the meaning
right now makes sense while you work on
yeah spacecraft propulsion
yes exactly like literal rocket science
natalia this is amazing conversation
you're working on such an exciting
engineering field and i think this is
like what
20th uh 21st century will be remembered
for as space exploration so
this is super exciting uh space that
you're working on
so and thank you so much for spending
your time
with me today thanks for having me this
was fun
you